times i feel angry this is something
that we've been
dealing with for a long time
as a black man i'm fed up tired i want
change
now if you're an african-american and
you can't even be
safe in your own home then where do you
feel safe
[Applause]
we need to change people's hearts it's a
mindset
this goes beyond just what we see on
camera enough is enough
this means too much to all of us
man this this moment is big it's a lot
to be in this situation today the same
situation we was in five years ago same
situation we was in
10 years ago and so on and so forth it's
just an ongoing cycle
we will not be silent it's taken a very
long time
to get this sort of momentum going and
it can't be lost
there's so much to change discrimination
profiling these things have to stop we
will not let up
that will never be silent or distraction
we can still play basketball
but at the end of the day social justice
has to be had
we will turn pain into progress we have
to find a way
to come together as a whole it doesn't
matter what your ethnicity is
we're all in this fight together the
question is how can i help
how can i step into this moment in time
our country's not going to go back to
normal
like there's going to be a new normal
and right now we're going to decide what
that normal is going to be
we want our lives to be valued as much
as everybody else you know we don't
think that we're better we want to be
seen as equals and
you know to this point we haven't one
man
i don't care what happens as far as
these games or
uh or life comes back to normal or
whatnot things aren't going to change
until we sort of make them change
and we will make change
tonight's presentation of the national
anthem has been recorded by music
musician producer activist and louisiana
native john batiste
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
john bertis
[Music]
so you saw players coaches
game officials alike all taking a knee
in orlando
just before the start of game one of the
nba's
restart been 140 days
since we have seen an nba game that
counts
yes that was a bit